so nine progressive groups have joined
together to help stop the rioting that's
destroying our cities
i lie they're petitioning to tape delay
the convention
in order to fact check the speakers
because those are all lies
cnn called it a parade of lies as the
leading fake news network i guess they
were frightened of the competition
so here's their biggest lie
we had multiple speakers from
congressman steve scalise and jim jordan
tout economic records that have been
obliterated by the pandemic they cited
the lowest unemployment rate in 50 years
well we don't have that anymore we're
now at 10.2 percent higher than at any
time
uh since the great recession really
really yeah well for that to be a lie
you must be an
idiot for you assume america can't
factor the shutdown's effects on the
numbers
but then again it is cnn fact is those
were in amazing numbers before the
shutdown
and even trump's usual critics know that
disputing them is
too stupid a path to take but not that
bozo
the reality the trump economy was so
powerful it's still withstanding a
hurricane
disguised as a disease other lies fall
into the usual muddy area of opinion
there's one about trump downplaying the
pandemic this after noting
the devastating impact on jobs from the
shutdown
that trump initiated that's some
downplaying
shutting down travel the economy getting
ventilators to those who claimed were
needed
and trump did this without killing
people in rest homes
maybe he should write a book about it
include pictures so andrew cuomo can
understand it
of course they ignore the dems and even
experts who really downplayed it
and you could find those pretty easy our
biggest concern to you
to you to you at home right now today is
influenza
it's not coronavirus sandra you were
telling us the last hour
that we there's an important context we
need to keep this in and that is that
the flu
is more deadly yeah how worried should
americans be
about coronavirus corona virus is not
going to cause a major issue in the
united states half the people in america
do not get a flu shot
and the flu right now is far deadlier so
if you're freaked out at all about the
coronavirus you should be
more concerned about the flu uh who's
downplaying
what honest mistakes because they were
preoccupied
i still wonder how this pandemic would
look now if the government hadn't been
hijacked by phony collusion myths and a
full-blown impeachment
lives would have been saved many lives
but knowing the dems they'd blame trump
for overpopulating the planet
so katie uh it's amazing when these fact
checkers suddenly wake up for the
republicans
yeah this uh daniel dale who you had on
after the dnc he was like oh there's
just not that much to do
there's just not that much fact checking
to do you know fact checkers are just
liberal reporters with a different title
um
they pretend that they are arbiters of
the truth that they are
fair that they're looking at both sides
of an issue but when you look at what
they're actually fact checking it's very
clear that they're no different
than the other 93 percent of
reporters that identify on the left you
know jesse
the when they fact check they always
tend to put a spin on it it's like when
the republican says
they sent a pallet of cash to iran the
fact-checker says
no they didn't they sent a pallet of
cash to iran
but it was meant for
something else and blah blah and it's
like yeah we'll just take the first part
of the sentence thank you very much
right they're just like the dnc rapid
response
i predict the fact checker is going to
probably have a job in a democratic
political campaign
because cnn probably isn't paying him
that well i love
to dana's point earlier you have the
republicans who have their convention
and they say
marauding mobs of socialists are going
to destroy your family and your business
and then you have the dnc saying donald
trump will destroy democracy
pile up black bodies and give you covid
19.
and the media says the democrats are
uplifting and unifying and the
republicans are dark
they're saying the exact same thing and
the fact that i
jesse waters has the intellectual
honesty
to say that both parties paint dire
pictures
of the other party if they're in charge
and cnn doesn't
tells you a lot juan do you agree with
jesse
that he's being honest no
you know what you know what strikes me
is facts
are stubborn things they're real facts
when do you hear the trump people say oh
yeah he's done a great job with the
coronavirus you think oh
did they miss a hundred and seventy
thousand americans i know he killed
those people once
he killed those people how dare he kill
those people that's a fact
and another fact is
trump promised four percent gdp growth
never achieved
under trump never that's a lie it's a
problem
that's a fact to live with i mean
similarly
you know when you point out failures
like that
that's very hard and yet somehow you
guys want to excuse it it's just oh well
what's the difference
but facts are facts i i missed your
facts
dana just the fact that i think that
last week the fact checkers got the week
off but
yes that was okay because you can't fact
check emotions
right yep there was one thing last week
that ap the ap
last week did fact check michelle
obama's speech um when she talked about
putting kids in cages and they said wait
hold on a second
that whole policy the the cages were
built like that was under the obama
administration so i did see that
one fact check but i did notice that
they fact-checked nikki haley for
calling
biden's public option government-run
healthcare but if you remember
when obamacare was being passed
democrats openly campaigned
on this being the step to get to
medicare for all
so i don't think that that fact check
needed to be done also a fact check was
when they said
if we did nothing nothing against the
coronavirus
we could see between 1.5 and 2 million
deaths and that if we had actually done
something it could be anywhere from 150
000 to 250 000
that was in the data